and now we present amazing facts about
the whale shark the whale shark is the
largest shark in the ocean growing to a
maximum of 65 feet long and weighing
over 10 tons that's more than three
times the size of the formidable great
white shark it also makes the whale
shark the largest fish living today
unlike great whites however the whale
sharks 3,000 teeth are tiny and they do
not repeat do not use them to tear apart
mammals in fact their teeth are a little
use so what does a whale shark eat to
survive for that we need a quick sidebar
you're watching the spawning ritual of
the dog snapper the dog snappers parade
up the water at the top of the parade
loop the females lay their eggs in the
males release their sperm which leads to
whale shark chow
the whale shark is what's called a
filter feeder as it swims with its huge
four foot wide mouth open prey like
these dogs snapper eggs gets trapped in
a sieve or rakers while water is
expelled right back out through the
gills but dog snapper eggs aren't the
only caviar these big mouse loved wheat
kubera gather in deep water and form a
cyclone that whirls toward the surface
the female turns white to attract males
they swarm her in a frenzy releasing
sperm as she releases her eggs a single
kubera female can release tens of
thousands of eggs a night for as many as
five nights in a row
and since whale sharks can process over
1,500 gallons of water each hour that
means plenty of kubera eggs here for the
gulping after all this monster of a
shark has no interest in chopping a big
baby human as long as they have their
more delicate tiny prey around these
giants are sure to be satisfied